all right
good morning
dear colleagues today's key debate is on
Russia's escalation of its war of
aggression against Ukraine
on the 30th of September after Russia
staged a series of sham referenda it
illegally annexed the occupied
territories of Ukraine in what is a
blatant violation of Ukraine sovereignty
territorial integrity and international
law
so on behalf of the European Parliament
let me reiterate
Donetsk herzon luhansk and zaporiza just
like Crimea are and will remain part of
independent and Sovereign Ukraine
and no sham referenda can ever change
this
so it is my pleasure to now give the
floor behalf of the council
to Joseph Burrell just open the debate
after which we give the floor the
president of the commission holds
lavender line so we're really on the
floor
good morning I'm going to speak in
Spanish
foreign
tambien
Plano
was
ejo
aprobando La
propustion is
personalized
technology
is Russia
because
foreign
dependencies
foreign
foreign
foreign
no flakea
foreign
bolsas
foreign
foreign
foreign
controversion
is
civil
yes
consequences
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Village
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
diplomatica
is
foreign
foreign
very much to the high representative
next I give the floor commission
president Russell love on the line
please
thank you president Roberta
Minister HIV pedia Joseph honorable
members
it's just four weeks ago that we met
here in the Hemi cycle
for the State of the Union but in those
four weeks the Kremlin has escalated its
aggression to a new level
Putin has launched Russia's first
mobilization since World War II
treating hundreds of thousands of young
Russians as Canon father
he uses Shem referendum in an illegal
attempt to change International borders
by force
and since many months he is using energy
as a weapon
now of course we feel that the Russian
war causes economic and social hardship
and it places a heavy burden on our
citizens and on the economy in our
single Market we see in particular the
rising Energy prices and gas and
electricity prices that are leading to
reduced purchasing power and they are
leading to a loss of competitiveness for
our business in the international market
but our resilience
in all these difficult times is
remarkable
and what we have to do is work steadily
on our resilience mainly on the field of
energy and that's where I want to focus
on today
if you look at the course of this last
seven months together with our member
states we have already taken important
steps
we have diminished our gas consumption
by around 10 that's good it's not enough
we have to do more but it's a big step
forward
I want to give you two figures what the
Russian supplies of gas are concerned at
the beginning of the war if you look at
all the Imports of gas
Russian the Russian share was 41 percent
within seven months we've gone down to
7.5 that's good
and we have compensated this decrease in
Russian supplies by a massive increase
by our trusted suppliers for example the
United States for example Norway
let's look at gas storage that is almost
at 90 percent by now
this is 15 higher than on the same day
last year
three weeks ago in this hemicycle
I announced that we will skim the
exceptional profits that electricity
producing companies have these days to
make them available for member states to
support vulnerable citizens and
businesses
now last week already we haven't tried
that in law EU law we achieved that
Enlightenment speak and I really want to
thank the Czech presidency for this
outstanding deliverable in really a very
very short time and yesterday
the council reached agreement on repower
EU
so we will have key instruments in place
to make it through the winter that's
starch and saving to jointly purchase
gays gas this is our platform
to get rid of the grip the Russians have
on us through their fossil fuels
these are our agreements with other
friends
to redistribute the windfall profits to
support those in need and to invest in
the future of a sustainable energy
Supply and that is repower EU
the measures we have put in place
provide us with a first buffer of
protection and thanks to these
we can and we will now step up to the
next level
I will lay out a road map in a letter to
leaders in view of our meeting in Prague
in two days this week
and I want to discuss with you
firsthand the key components of this
letter
of course it's all about energy prices
so we will step up our negotiations with
trusted partners for example with
Norway's to dampen the price we pay for
gas Imports
the talks have already started
I think as a European Union we have a
considerable Market power
and many of our suppliers want to
conclude deals with us which are
beneficial for two sides both sides so I
really think it is necessary that we
come to an agreed Corridor of prices to
stop this crazy Peaks we have partially
in the import of gas prices
we will strengthen our energy platform
and he let let me be very clear it is in
our Collective interest
after the winter we will have to refill
the gas storages and if we then see that
we have again a scenario where member
states are outbidding each other on the
global market and that's Rising the
prices here in the European Union this
is not sustainable so we have to have a
joint procurement of all member states
this is much better than the way we have
it
my next point is on gas prices
and as you know we use gas in three
different domains for industry
for heating and for the production of
electricity
let me start with the electricity
our market for electricity is built in a
way
that high gas prices are driving
electricity prices
we have now to limit this inflationary
impact of gas on electricity and
everywhere in Europe
this is why
we are ready to discuss a cup
on the price of gas that is used to
generate electricity
this cap would also be a first step on
the way to a structural reform an
overall reform of our electricity Market
but I think we also have to have a look
at gas prices beyond the electricity
market so where industry is concerned
where heating is also concerned the
general approach of gas
and here we will work together with
member states to reduce gas prices and
to limit volatility and thus to limit
the impact of price manipulation by
Russia because if you look at the fever
curve of gas and gas prices the whole
gas price you can see the manipulation
that Russia has on the gas prices and
this has to stop
we have already
offered this mechanism in March
at that time we've said that it can give
an important signal
that you will not pay any price for gas
anymore
we have qualified such a price cap as
having an immediate impact on price
levels but
that it entails drawbacks in terms of
security of supply
this is still true today so it's a fine
line to walk it's not trivial to do that
but the situation since March has
critically evolved since then and today
compared to March
member states are open now for it more
member states are open for it and we are
better prepared
such a cap on gas prices must be
designed properly
to ensure security of supply
and it is a temporary solution to cater
for the fact
that the ttf that is our main price
Benchmark is no longer representative
for our Market
this ttf benchmark
reflects or mirrors a lot pipeline guns
but in the last seven months we have
because we wanted to get rid of the
dependency on Russian gas we have
increased a lot the LNG market and this
LNG Market is not probably reflected in
the ttf
so introducing a cap
on gas overall is a temporary solution
until we will have a new EU Price Index
developed that ensures a better
functioning of the market and the
commission has already started to work
on this
honorable members these are far-reaching
measures
and I wholeheartedly agree with you
when you say in the the resolution you
will vote on today
that exceptional times require
exceptional measures where the union
needs to act as jointly and as United as
ever
in pursuing our action two same things
remain Paramount
that is action and unity
and action and solidarity
if I look at our single Market we really
need to protect the fundamentals of our
economy and in particular our single
Market
the single Market is the strength of our
European Union
and this is where the wealth of the
European Union comes from
without a common European solution we
risk fragmentation if every member State
goes on its own we have fragmentation we
don't want and we have to do something
against it
thank you
and therefore it is so Paramount
that we preserve a Level Playing Field
within the European Union in our single
Market every member state is benefiting
from it as I said the wealth comes from
our single Market
now what does that mean with real power
issue
we have developed a crucial instrument
to accelerate the transition in the
energy Independence that's what we're
working on since seven months
and repower EU will allow it's the
governance structure it will allow the
investment in infrastructure for example
pipelines for example interconnectors
for example Renewables
but it also allows and that's important
to support businesses or households to
invest in Energy Efficiency for example
insulating houses or installing heat
pumps or installing new technology for
the companies the businesses that have
to do the transition
now here's my proposal
I think we should further boost we power
EU with additional funding common
European funding
this way
All European states can accelerate the
necessary investment All European member
states
we modernize our infrastructure the
energy infrastructure we preserve the
Level Playing Field and we secure our
European competitiveness on the global
market
so we have to do this investment we have
to do this funding together as Europeans
jointly with a common solution
and honorable members allow me to speak
about another pressing issue which we
have to address today
sabotage against North stream Pipelines
have shown how vulnerable our energy
infrastructure is
for the first time in recent history
it has become a Target
pipelines and underwater cables connect
European citizens and companies to the
world they are the lifeline of data and
energy
it is in the interest of all Europeans
to better protect this critical
infrastructure
and for this I will present a five-point
plan
first we must be better prepared
we have very recently agreed new
legislation that's good which will
strengthen the resilience of critical EU
entities
the responsible Parliament committee
will be voting on it next week that's
good too so we are absolutely on time
and I think we can and we should already
now work be working on this basis
second
we need to stress test our
infrastructure
we don't have to wait till something
happens but we need to make sure that we
are prepared and therefore we need those
stress tests
we need to identify whether we have weak
points and where these weak points are
and of course we have to prepare our
reaction to sudden disruption what are
we doing then are all the information
chains in place is everybody informed
does this
um emergency scenario really work then
in our single Market
we will work with member states to
ensure effective stress tests in the
energy sector
and this then should be followed by
other high-risk sectors such as the
offshore digital
and the electricity infrastructure
my third point
we will increase our capacity
to respond through our civil protection
mechanism well known to you in the
European Union
with this we can support member states
in addressing the disruption of critical
infrastructure for example with fuel
with generators with necessary shelter
capacity
my first point we will make best use of
our satellite surveillance capacity we
have them settle as in place we have the
capacity to do the surveillance to
detect potential threats so this is also
a matter of prevention and awareness and
finally
we will strengthen our cooperation with
NATO
and with key Partners like the United
States on this critical issue
honorable members
this warm
has entered in a new phase
the Ukrainian Army keeps reporting
impressive successes in its fight
against the aggressor
we all saw the images of deeply relieved
people welcoming Ukrainian soldiers
and I could see with my own eyes when I
was three weeks ago and Kiev that life
has come back to Kiev
of course it is The Bravery of the
Ukrainian people that made it possible
but I think Europe's contribution also
has made a huge difference and now it's
the time to keep track to help the
ukrainians to Face Down The Invader a
strong and steadfast Europe that will
only be the only way to stop putting
this is the moment to stay the course
and to signal again to our Ukrainian
fence we stay by your side as long as it
takes thank you and Long Live Europe
thank you very much
commission president I give the floor
now to